and we are now ready to prove oiler
cerium that will help us to find passes
visiting every agency graph exactly once
actually we will be focusing on the
ovarian cycle problem find in cycles at
visits every edge in the graph because
earlier was interested in a walkthrough
Konigsberg that starts and ends at the
same place there is cosmetic very small
differences between finding covariant
cycles in order in process as soon as we
learn how to find cycles we will learn
how to find passes and vice verse let me
start from a question does this graph
has an already encyc oh oh in other
words is this graph ovarian of course
not because there is no way out of the
read node what about this graph it's
also known already because there is no
way in into the read node and what about
this graph we need to look a little bit
more close but we will immediately find
a red node here for which there is one
incoming and two outgoing edge which
means that this graph cannot possibly be
already because in every all variant
cycle the number of times the nth entry
node equals to the number of time we
leave the node and therefore the number
of incoming edges in every node should
be equal to the number of outgoing edges
from every node the call graph balance
if in degree of every node equal to its
out degree or in other words the number
of incoming edges into every node equals
to the number of outgoing edges is this
graph balance of course we can check
that for every node there are two
incoming and outgoing headers but it
doesn't help us yet to figure out over
the series an honorarium cycle in this
graph and now they are ready to present
over Syria they already saw that every
all variant graph is balanced so this
graph has a chance to be aware
all approved that every balance graph is
already of course balanced and strongly
connected because if the graph is
disconnected there is no way to find in
origin
SEC let's prove this area and to prove
the serum we need to recruit an end and
let it randomly walk through the graph
of course with the conditions that the
ant cannot visit the same edge twice
let's start if ant was genius then he
would simply walk along the graph as I
show here visited all edges of the graph
and finally return back but an average
aunt wouldn't be that lucky and it would
start traveling through the graph start
to working and eventually it would get
stuck let's stop for a second and sank
at what node this hand can possibly get
stuck can it get stuck in the middle of
the graph presumably not because our
graph is balanced and therefore every
time the ant is entering country node
there should be way out of the node this
condition holds for all nodes in the
graph except for one with each one of
course it's the starting node of them
because in this starting node the end
has already used the first outgoing edge
so it may arrive in this note answer
will be no outgoing edges left and
therefore what we learn that the ant can
only get stuck at the node where it
started of what can we do afterwards
then failed to construct the all variant
cycle because it did not visit all edges
of the graph but maybe just maybe we can
start at a different node in the green
cycle let's start at a different node at
the green cycle also it's not clear what
difference does it make but why
shouldn't we try to
start in a note in the cycle where our
still unexplored edges for example at
this note in the cycles there are still
unexplored edges left so let's for that
to start here at this note and in the
beginning let's tell them first follows
the same cycle you construct it at the
previous step so then start working
along the green cycle then absolutely
doesn't understand why he has to do this
kind of silly Brook working along the
cycles that he already constructed but
finally he arrives to the initial note
and now he realized that actually now he
can continue working because the rest
still unexplored edges from this know
then continues working continues work in
continuous working and finally got stuck
and of course it got stuck it's the same
note where it started what we should do
today afterwards then afterwards we
should start at another node will be
still unexplored edges where is this
node it be well this is the node we
still unexplored edges then first will
be ordered to traverse the cycles it has
been already constructed this is green
blue cycle and then starts continue
continue continues and is not happy but
it's ok continue and finally arrives to
the initial node but now they ain't
realizes that the instruction be honest
that's stupid because there is a
possibility to explore further and the
continue continue continue
and finally they ant constructed the
cycle that we wanted that visits every
edge of the graph exactly once not only
and constructed this cycle we actually
just came up with is an algorithm for
doing this and this should occur
describe our instructions to them and
you can implement it it it will result
in an efficient algorithm and if we
would now put an end to search
debryn graph constructed for universal
strength in this case just in three
iteration it will construct ovarian
cycle and therefore a constructor
universal strength you can check that
you will can be able to derive universal
strength from this cycle